WILFRED MCCLAY: It's different
than the kind of acts
of imagination that go with
fiction, because history
actually happened.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We rode in on a horse
that we didn't create.
Well, you ought
to know something
about that horse and the
horses before it and before it
and before it.
SPEAKER 1: Well, come on.
What are we waiting for?
WILFRED MCCLAY: If we look
at the times we're living in,
the graph goes,
vroom, like this,
in terms of every measure of
material prosperity longevity,
health, et cetera.
But we don't know
that if we don't know
what things were like before.
[CHATTER]
SPEAKER 2: It's up to
us to enjoy life in full
and to make it count.
WILFRED MCCLAY:
There's a tendency
to think we can decide questions
of principle by reference only
to abstractions.
Now, history is concrete.
History fills in the blanks
with real world events
and real people, things
that actually happened.
And we can test
out our principles
by seeing how they
operate in history.
LARRY P. ARNN: Good history
would be an accurate picture
of what happened in the past.
There's a sympathy
for the people
so that one can learn from them.
It gives us a
fixity that is made
of things that, at the
time, were constantly
shifting and hard to estimate.
FRANKLIN D. ROOSEVELT: It
is possible, of course.
JOHN F. KENNEDY: --of
landing a man on the moon
and returning him
safely to the earth.
WILFRED MCCLAY: I
think US history
is a really extraordinary moment
in the history of the world.
The story of this country is
one of the most interesting,
exciting, compelling
stories that you
could tell about human
life on this planet.
Returning to our
history and seeing
why things happened
the way they did
can give us some insight that
we might not otherwise have.
The study of
history expands you.
You learn to empathize
with very different ways
of living in the past.
I think that's fun.
I'd put it up against anything.
I'm Wilfred McClay, professor
of history and letters.
This is our course
in American history.
RONALD REAGAN:
And determination.
WILFRED MCCLAY: Let's begin.
[MUSIC PLAYING]